[Music]
i
am attracted to the bluebirds because of
their beauty
[Music]
my name is al larsen
i'm 97 years old or young
these bluebirds are about 11 days old
i've helped over 40 000 nestlings
every living thing has just as much
right to live as i do
[Music]
i'm a bird watcher by
choice i guess
when i retired
in the late
70s last 1970s
i came upon this article in national
geographic and i became aware of the
plight of the bluebird their population
has been declining and the importance of
the mess box to the survival of the
bluebirds and i thought well why don't i
try that here
so one of the first nest boxes i set up
a bluebird moved into it
and immediately hey
success
i should put up more boxes
[Music]
oh this is a second nest you can see
different material built on top there
well we'll go on to the next box now
see what's going on there
these nest boxes that i use
are ones that i built at home
i came up with a solution of building
the box as simply as possible
cheap to build with just four sides a
bottom and a roof anybody could build it
even kids
over the years i have added more than
350 nest boxes out
my bluebird trails cover quite an area
in southwest idaho actually i've got a
trail in each of five different counties
i monitor the boxes regularly to record
the data of what goes on with the
development of the nesting cycle of the
bluebirds i've shared
my data with boise state university the
banding laboratory at patuxent maryland
and anybody else who requested
[Music]
pretty little bluebird
where do you go
come back come back to me
i'm going says a bird as he flew on high
to see if my color matches the sky
i'm gratified to know that i've helped
the bluebirds increase their population
i'm gratified to know that through the
work i've done i've inspired many many
other people to help not only bloopers
but other creatures as well
so maybe i've been put here to help our
environment
my message is you've got to be active if
you're going to get old
don't crawl into a cocoon because you
might not break out of it
so
think about the future and what you can
do tomorrow
plan ahead
you